mais pour établir ce rapport sur
l'informatisation de la société simon
aura je vous le disais à travailler avec
alain minc qui est aujourd'hui notre
invité pour cette première lettre à l'an
2000 de la saison 78 une lettre que nous
vous présenterons désormais chaque
dimanche midi le rapport n'aura minc ami
à la mode un mot qui s'appelle la
télématique nous sommes dans une salle
ici équipé de visiophone c'est-à-dire de
téléviseurs couplés à des téléphones où
on voi interlocuteur à qui on parle
alors monsieur minc est ce qu'à votre
avis est salée ce visiophone symbolise
un peu la télématique
oui cette salle symbolisa télématique
mais elle n'est pas tout la télématique
en tout cas elle montre le mariage des
images des sons et un jour aussi les
transmissions de données que nous avons
baptisé la télématique les performances
que nous faisons le fait que nous
dialoguons d'un endroit à un autre et
qui n'auront plus à prendre l'avion
c'est un peu ça à télématique
alors si nous passons aux applications
de cette télématique et les conséquences
que cela peut avoir pour notre société
quelles sont ses conséquences les
premières que vous voyez la télématique
se diffusera d'abord dans les
entreprises et dans les grandes
organisations
ce sera un moyen de communication
beaucoup plus rapides beaucoup plus
immédiat permettant d transmission et
des changements d'activité
ensuite elle entrera dans notre vie
quotidienne alors nous dialoguerons plus
nous sucrer nous utiliserons ceci pour
accéder à des banques de données nous
réserverons électroniquement elle nous
place de trains nous ferons nous
commandent dentelle quand l'entreprise
de vente par correspondance
nous programmons et nos activités mais
ceci quand nous le voudrons il n'y a pas
de fatalité
est ce que vous croyez que la société
française ou autre va finalement choisir
un schéma qui ressemble à celui d'une
grande entreprise puisque c'est le même
outil qui va passer de la grande
entreprise au domaine public
non le l'outil n'exerce aucune fatalité
la société utilisera cet outil dans
l'entreprise d'une certaine façon dans
les collectivités locales d'une autre
façon dans les villes où on aura des
systèmes télématiques d'une manière
particulière comme au japon que comme
vous l'avez montré l'outil
maintenant est parfaitement libre nous
en ferons ce que nous voudrons bon alors
cet outil parfaitement libre comment le
recevrons nous chez nous est ce que ce
sera sous la forme d'un micro ordinateur
d'un téléviseur ou est-ce qu'il faudra
se rendre quelque part pour l'utiliser
le jour où la télématique nous atteindra
chez nous ce sera à l'aide d'un
téléphone à touches
le clavier à touches sera le moyen
d'accès à l'extérieur le téléviseur nous
servira à recevoir des images ce sera en
fait un écran et entre les deux il y
aura une sorte de petit ordinateur dont
nous jouerons et que nous utiliserons
pour certaines tâches
est ce qu'il ya des domaines où la
france est particulièrement en avance ou
alors au contraire complètement dépassé
il ya aucun domaine où la france est
complètement dépassée dieu merci il y à
un certain nombre de domaines en
informatique et aussi en matière de
télécommunications et notre présence
dans cette salle
en témoigne où la france a une avance
technique qui a une capacité technique
elle peut très largement valorisé il ya
on n'imaginait pas du tout que la
micro-informatique allait exister
aujourd'hui elle commence à envahir un
peu le
le foyer alors monsieur minc est ce que
c'est un bien ce que c'est un mâle est
ce que vous voyez l'évolution de ce
phénomène
elle n'en aie pas encore le foyer elle
va peut-être l'envahir dans les années
qui viennent
c'est un bien si nous savons bien nous
en servir en l'occurrence la micro
informatique
c'est un outil c'est un outil dont on
peut faire ce qu'on veut donc ce sera un
bien si nous sommes capables de bien
l'utiliser
ce sera un mal si nous sommes maladroit
rigide autoritaire avec nous mêmes est
ce que comme pour la télématique les
micro ordinateurs qui sont en vente ici
pourront être manipulé par quelqu'un qui
décidera lui même de ce qu'il va faire
dès lors qu'il sera l'utiliser con qu'il
sera le programme et il décidera lui
même de ce qu'il va faire en effet c'est
un outil de liberté parce que la micro
informatique et pour une conséquence
logique de la macro informatique
non la micro-informatique et filles
d'une révolution technique
extraordinaire qui est celle des
composants électroniques qui nous
l'avons écrit ont connu une baisse de
prix tels qu'une rolls faudrait
aujourd'hui en france ça change beaucoup
de choses une rolls intrants est ce que
vous pensez que dans un autre domaine
mais toujours dans l'informatique il est
possible de voir une découverte aussi
importante que celle ci celle de la
micro-informatique et bouleverser
complètement tout ce qu'on imagine
aujourd'hui je ne crois pas à la
futurologie mais je crois aux
découvertes donc je pense qu'il y aura
des découvertes mais je ne sais
lesquelles